[Music]
hello dear friends uh Pastor Steven bore
here having the privilege to uh try and
answer the questions that you have sent
us in the course of many months uh this
is a question and answer program called
I'd like to know uh you send us your
questions we do everything in our power
to find a Biblical answer to share with
you on the air and so thank you for
being with us if you want to send your
questions this is the address TVM
tv.org you've seen it on the screen TVM
tv.org I have with me uh Pastor David
Salasar who is on our staff here in
charge of the Latino work and it's
always nice to work with you Pastor
thank you Pastor Bor it's always a
privilege as well for me to share and to
work side by side with you amen um we
want to begin with a word of prayer
never should we open God's word without
prayer so I'm wondering if you'd be able
to pray for us absolutely let us pray
Heavenly Father we come before you at
this hour to ask that you will give us a
portion of your holy spirit that we may
receive the instruction from your word
and may we be able to answer the
questions that our friends have sent not
for us to be be proud of most of our
knowledge but to truly Point them to the
Bible to the truth to the spirit
prophecy that they may receive a
blessing for them and light to their
lives we thank you for being with us and
once again we ask you that you will be
in their midst we pray in Jesus name
amen
amen well we have some very engaging
questions today
and uh I'm going to read the first one
and I'm going to ask Pastor Salasar to
share with us um the material that he
has uh researched and found in answer to
the
question um actually there's two
questions but they're very closely
related correct the first is how can we
separate the period between the special
resurrection and the first resurrection
basically the idea is how long is there
between the special Resurrection maybe
some people don't know what the special
Resurrection is and the general
resurrection of the righteous and the
second question is and what is the
agreement between Daniel
122 and Revelation 1 and verse 7 so
let's take the first question uh how
much time is there between the special
resurrection and the general
Resurrection or are they the same thing
well Pastor bour that's a good question
and uh as you mentioned I think I think
the ma the first thing is to establish
if there's such a thing as a special
Resurrection if there's such a concept
in the Bible uh there's not a the
specific word special Resurrection in
the Bible That's not found in the
scripture but we have to look into the
Bible what does it say in regards to the
resurrection now we know and we have I
mean there's enough evidence in the
Bible about Jesus Christ coming the
second time and when he comes with a V
voice of a you know angel with the Trump
of God the dead in Christ shall
resurrect that's what Apostle Paul
mentions in 1 Thessalonians chapter 5 so
we know that at the time of Christ's
second coming there will be a general
resurrection of the uh just where those
who have died and asleep in Jesus have
will receive the resurrection will be
alive and will be uh will meet in the
Lord in the air as long along along with
those that are actually living the
righteous living but Christ mentions
something specifically and I'm going to
go to the Book of Matthew
2664 now this is Jesus speaking at his
trial in the presence of the uh high
priest Kias and Sanhedrin he was accused
of you know of of sedition of trying to
uh be a false Messiah a false Christ and
they wanted to kill him to crucify him
but he mentions there in chapter 26
verse
64 when or I'll actually read verse 63
Jesus was silent in that trial and it
says there but Jesus kept silent and the
high priest answered and said to him I
adure you by the Living God that you
tell us if you are the Christ the son of
God
Jesus notice what he says vers 64 Jesus
said to him it is as you said
nevertheless I say to you Hereafter you
will see the son of man sitting at the
right hand of the power and coming on
the Clouds Of Heaven here Christ tells
the high priest you know and those in
the Sanhedrin that were there that he
was indeed the Christ and that he would
be seen by
them at his coming in the Clouds Of
Glory so Christ is letting them know
these individuals that are there those
that are you know looking to destroy or
or or put him to death that they will be
eyewitnesses of his second coming so now
this is a group that is part of this
special Resurrection which would be a
resurrection of those who are who were
you know those that pierced Jesus those
that try to you know uh deceive the the
the the Israelites into betraying the
Lord now not only are those individuals
part of this this um group not only are
the high priest Kias and and those that
pierce Jesus but also uh if we go to the
Book of Revelation chapter 14
I I think there's also a blessing and
this is where uh you know and you
probably Pastor B will actually add a
lot more to what I'm saying but in
Revelation chapter 14 and verse
13 um there is a blessing to those who
actually have kept the Commandments of
God who have understood and received the
Three Angels messages and it says there
then I heard verse 13 a voice from
Heaven saying to me write blessed are
the Dead who died in the Lord From Now
On In other words those who have
received the Three Angels messages who
have received the knowledge of the of
this message that is to be given to the
world at the last time they are blessed
because they will die in the Lord from
henceforth and yes says the spirit that
they may rest from their labors and
their Works follow them so here in the
Bible there's this declaration that
those that died after receiving the
Three Angels messages or have embraced
the truth of three Angel's messages
those who are in that time will have or
are especially blessed because they
are going to have and where H you know
where I I I believe we'll be we'll be
coming back to Daniel chapter 12 in this
case Daniel 12 verse 2 uh where it says
there that many of those who sleep in
the dusts of the Earth shall awake some
to everlasting life some to shame and
everlasting contempt this is the special
Resurrection that's prior to Jesus come
that will come that will allow those who
die in the three angel messages to come
forth and those who pierce the Lord here
that's why it says some are uh some the
just and some who are going for contempt
and everlasting contempt these are the
people that are are resurrected and
prior to Christ's coming and see him and
see the last scenes of the Earth's
history seemen be you know fulfilled and
the second coming of Christ so this is
how the special Resurrection is
portrayed in the Bible in in a nutshell
so there's a special Resurrection yes of
the wicked yes and a special
resurrection of the righteous correct
now we know that
cifas and we know that those who appear
pierced him mhm are resurrecting in a
special
Resurrection because all of the wicked
are going to die after the thousand
years correct not at the second coming
correct so because cifas and those who
Pierce Jesus are going to see him coming
in the clouds at the second coming yes
that has to be a special Resurrection
because all of the other Wicked
according to Revelation 20 resurrect
after the thousand years correct correct
and and that's that's the thing you as
you mentioned Pastor the the you know
the verse uh actually in verse 7
Revelation 1:7 it says behold he's
coming in the clouds and every ey shall
see him and they also who Pierce him so
this fulfills that promise or that
Revelation or the prophecy of Daniel
12:2 where he mentions that some are
resurrected for condemnation you know
because they are resurrected they see
the Lord come they realize I mean he is
the Son of God we kill him we Pierce him
and they are resurrected for
condemnation for dnation while the
righteous living are resurrected to see
the Lord but the special Resurrection
also is for some righteous who are going
to be rewarded by seeing the last events
before the second coming of Christ so
they can actually see the
whole uh you know the whole fulfillment
and fall before their eyes so they are
eyewitnesses of his full coming not just
after Christ comes and the resurrected
will hear his voice and and just see him
hear they will actually see the final
sequence yeah of events and if somebody
like Martin Luther yeah resurrected in
that special Resurrection he wouldn't
have any idea what's going on exactly
whereas those who die in the in the
Three Angels messages yes who lived in
the end time correct they're going to
exact know exactly mhm that the that the
righteous have just been delivered by
the voice of God the righteous living
right and that they are participating in
the special Resurrection which they
understood Martin Luther and others
previously did not understand this so
they're going to resurrect and they're
going to know exactly what's happening
yeah um you know let me just give it a
little bit of chronology you know some
people think that Jesus is simply going
to come the second time and that's it uh
but there are several events that take
place before uh before that uh for the
voice of God which is heard it is done
at that moment you have the special
resurrection of the righteous and the
wicked and at that moment the living
Saints are transformed they're given
their resurrected bodies and at that
very time those who died in the third
Angels message are going to resurrect as
well as those who resurrected the
special Resurrection right but at that
point Jesus hasn't even begun his second
coming yet mhm he if you read great
controversy page 635 to 643
you're going to find the whole sequence
there and Ellen White quotes bible
verses to sustain what she's saying you
know the voice of God free delivers the
Saints from the death decree and at that
time the wicked who crucified Christ
cifas among others resurrect those who
died in the third Angel's message
resurrect correct and and then you
continue reading there in great
controversy uh 635
642 and you'll find that after several
Pages it speaks about uh those who sleep
in the dust of the Earth are resurrected
when Jesus has basically con concluded
his second coming when he's above the
Earth uh and so uh there is a special
resurrection of a righteous group and of
a wicked group uh that will come forth
from the grave um before act Jesus
actually begins his second coming
you know the the Bible gives us the
sequence the general sequence in Matthew
24h and verse
29 you have first of all a reference to
the Great Tribulation yeah that's the
time of
trouble and then it says immediately
after the tribulation of those days now
you have signs in the heavens the sun
will be darkened the moon will not give
its
light and the Stars will fall from
Heaven yeah and the powers of the
heavens will be shaken the powers of the
heavens are the sun moon and stars so
you have the darkening of the Sun the
darkening of the moon and the falling of
the stars and then you have the next
event verse 30 then the sign of the son
of man will appear in heaven and the
sign of the son of man is that hand yes
about the Palm about half the size of a
palm of a man's hand which is the sign
that Jesus is beginning his second
coming correct and so it says then the
sign of man will be seen will appear in
heaven and then at that moment all the
tribes of the earth will mourn and they
will see the son of man uh let me see if
I get the page here they will see the
son of man uh coming on the Clouds Of
Heaven with power and great
glory and then at the conclusion of the
second coming while Jesus is still above
the Earth
it says and he will send his angels with
a great sound of a trumpet and they will
gather together his elect from the Four
Winds uh from the Four Winds from one
end of the heaven to the other and so
there you have the general uh structure
uh of the timing correct um you have the
conclusion of the Great Tribulation the
time of trouble the signs in the heavens
the sign of the son of man is seen mhm
those who Pierce Jesus
they will cry out yeah then you have
Jesus coming on the clouds with power
and glory and then when he's above the
Earth you have the sending of the angels
to pick up the righteous living and
those who died in Christ and resurrect
in the general Resurrection amen so I I
believe that with this information you
know we can certainly know that the
special Resurrection is indeed an event
that is given to to us especially those
who understand the TR messages as a as a
vision of Hope of of knowing that even
if you are put to sleep before the
second coming you will get to see how it
all unfolds so what a blessing to know
it's going to be a great blessing in
other words those who resurrect in the
special Resurrection are going to see
the totality of the second coming of
Christ am amen whereas those who
resurrect when Jesus is above the Earth
they're only going to see Jesus above
the earth when he call
right right so there's a special
privilege for those who resurrect in the
special Resurrection who are righteous
and die uh in the faith of the third
Angel's message amen
amen okay well I hope that helps let me
just uh mention uh to the person who
asked this question his name is George
doesn't give us a location um read the
great controversy page and by the way
I'm talking about the book not the
digital uh version of great controversy
because the paging isn't the same but in
the uh printed version of great
controversy the full version you're
going to find from page 635 it's called
God's people delivered through 642 643
you're going to find clearly all of the
sequence of events yeah from the time
that God's voice delivers the righteous
from the death decree and the special
Resurrection till the time that Jesus
comes and then after that you also have
the return to Heaven that Ellen White
describes in that chapter correct
correct okay so now we have uh the next
question this we should be able to
answer uh within the time
constraints uh this comes from
Christian uh Cathedral City
California my question is about First
Kings 7 23-
26 this passage describes a huge bronze
Basin resting on 12 oxen what was the
purpose of this Basin what was used for
thank you in advance so what's what's
all about that huge bronze Basin resting
on 12 oxen okay this first is actually
first king 7 so just a little mistake
there is first first Kings chapter 7: 22
and uh you know to 25 and it's in
regards to an Furniture a piece of
furniture for the temple that s King
Solomon was building the Temple that the
lord gave plans to King David for his
son to fulfill to build this Temple
which was the replacement of the
Tabernacle that was given to Moses but
it was destroyed the Tabernacle was
destroyed was not longer in service and
so they had a simple tent built
temporarily until the temple will be
built and so in this particular case
this uh basin BR bronze Basin uh that
was that's mentioned here in the
scripture that is also called The Sea of
cast bronze because it was a huge a huge
you know pool in a way in a way you know
place but this thing was uh you know it
was made in a way where 12,000 gallons
was could be poured into this you know
Basin and it's really the equivalent of
the labor in the Tabernacle service you
had the altar as you enter the
Tabernacle you know to the outer Court
you had the altar of sacrifice then you
had between the alter of sacrifice and
the entrance to the Tabernacle itself
you had the labor where the priests
would wash themselves and then they will
enter into the uh Tabernacle so this
element this sea of cast bronze or this
big Basin of bronze with 12 oxen this
was uh the replacement of that much
bigger much larger because it was uh
also made for a lot more well first of
all the temple was much bigger and so
there were a lot more priests that were
able could perform the sacrifices and
help the people and serve the people so
obviously had to be bigger and and this
is why proportionally speaking it was it
was bigger but it was a scale that was
just a bigger scale yeah there you know
there was no way that they could
transport the temp built by Solomon on
carts right the reason for the
Tabernacle being U something that could
be carried on carts yeah is because they
were on the way to the promised land
correct it was a a mobile if you p a
mobile tab Tabernacle yeah but when they
settled in the promised land yes uh then
they could build a permanent Temple but
when you really examine the pieces of
furniture and uh the dimensions you're
going to find that uh the tabern tacle
was a scale model mhm of the temple
built by Solomon right and the
Tabernacle and the temple built by solom
which is to scale to the uh Tabernacle
become types of even a greater Temple
which is the temple in heaven right um
which undoubtedly is also a scale model
yeah uh you know uh not a scale model
but it has Dimensions that are in
harmony with the scale model models of
the temple built by Solomon and also uh
the labor in the Tabernacle in the
wilderness so uh the short answer to
this is that uh that sea that is spoken
of in that huge Shu Basin uh is
equivalent to uh the labor yeah in the
Tabernacle in the wilderness correct and
of course it represents
baptism uh you know because Israel was
baptized in the Red Sea
according to 1 Corinthians chapter 10 so
uh and actually you have in the uh
Temple you have represented the death of
the Lamb is the death of Christ and then
you have the labor which represents his
resurrection then the holy place his
intercession then the most holy place
the Judgment uh and then his the uh
ceremony of the scapegoat which is the
end of the day of atonement correct uh
so you have all of the different phases
of the ministry of Christ illust rated
by the Tabernacle and the temple built
by Solomon and also the Heavenly Temple
absolutely and you you know also is
interesting that uh the temple that was
built after the Temple of Salomon was
destroyed the Third Temple uh which was
later expanded and became bigger under
Herod who you know built this you know
massive structure to make it even more
beautiful he wanted to be known or
Remember by making a temple that was
even better than Solomon which was a
bigger Temple uh they made again in in
scale proportionally speaking they made
every element bigger so they had a you
know for example I can't remember right
now the exact U elements but you know
the Temple of Solomon was a a size which
was a you know several times bigger than
the one in the wilderness and the Temple
of of U you know Herod that they built
in Jerusalem later was also much bigger
everything the altars were bigger
everything was bigger uh using the same
scale proportionately speaking but it
was just a way for them to um to keep
the connection to the original element
that Moses received as as a vision you
know from from heaven but like you said
pastor is really these were just
elements and even the furniture was a a
a type uh of of what heaven really had
you know and I remember when I first
visited uh uh Israel mhm uh on our tour
we were taken to a place where there's a
scale model of the the entire city of
Jerusalem in other words you have you
have it's it's pretty good sized and you
can see all of Jerusalem there but
that's not Jerusalem right it's a scale
model of the city as we know it now yeah
and so that's the how we need to
understand the Heavenly Temple is
humongous yes but it's the scale to the
temple built by Solomon and to the
Tabernacle in the wilderness well well
let me just say that uh we appreciate
you being with us for this question and
answer program uh I'd like to know as I
go different places uh is the favorite
program of most everybody that I speak
to they they enjoy sending questions and
getting answers I want to encourage you
to continue supporting Secrets unsealed
in some TV first of all through prayer
we need your prayers because that's
where the power is but also we want to
encourage you to to help us financially
because it takes resources Financial
Resources to do this program anchors
Summits and all of the production that
we do for television uh we appreciate
all of those who support this ministry
and if you're not help helping with this
ministry I would encourage you to help
us through your prayers and through your
financial support thank you so much we
appreciate it God bless you and we hope
to see you next time on this program I'd
like to know God bless
[Music]